hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver je rentre dans l'appli messenger
et tu table le styliste dû cliquer sur
démarrer pourquoi notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
j'ai mal au ventre vide
c'est la chronique yani ouais enfin
cyril avait envie du tout je vous
l'avais dit je vous le dis depuis
plusieurs jours chez comme un poids
ouais ouais boîte
non mais je vous dis j'ai pris des
médicaments je ne vais plus au toilette
norvège où il n'y a plus jamais non pas
par est pour quelque chose soit au jour
et voilà c'est juste un poil à voilà va
aller battre avaler faut que je souffre
allez faites votre émission toute façon
c'est votre cas échant quand un pub
inscrit qu'un bond champions bon alors
les amis qu'est-ce que j'ai regardé je
suis même plus parce que je vais pas
faire ce pas d'ailleurs je pense pas
comme ça ses préférences mais la somme
que j'aille pis m
[Applaudissements]
vous prenez pas la vie n'est pas la
maladie à plus de filtres en 3d d'où il
faut respecter pas la maladie mais bon
j'ai regardé fait-on projet sur france 2
et le matin